hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and I can't
believe that mha just revealed that
deku's Dad is actually the president of
the United States wow I guess now we
know why he's been away for work all
this time okay I'm kidding it's April
1st but we do have a real new chapter to
get through and things have gotten crazy
in the mha story International Heroes
movie only characters they're all here
and that's just the beginning all for
one was willingly betrayed by one of his
closest allies deck who is reaching his
limit and his body may be falling apart
as he struggles Against full power
shigaraki and the future of Japan and
the entire world depends on the outcome
of these battles so let's get into it
you guys know what to do leave a quick
like and comment right now to support us
in that YouTube algorithm and I have
some pretty huge news a brand new mha
video will be dropping very soon and I
can say that it is the best video we've
ever released that is coming in the next
day or two please subscribe right now
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss it I'm not kidding when I say
that this will hit different finally
this video will contain mha manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
chapter we learned how exactly
gigantomakia was released from his
confinement and how shinsel managed to
gain control of this monstrous villain
or I guess kind of gain control but more
on that later shinso was able to climb
up to Machias head and then use a
combination of his Persona chords and
his brainwashing Quirk to turn machia
against the villains the chapter Ended
as the battle against all for one in the
present moment reached an absolute fever
pitch and began to resemble a
mythological Clash of gods from Greek
mythology the battle between the
Olympian gods and the Titans the
titanomakia the latest chapter picks up
right where the previous left off with
all the heroes and gigantomakia team up
against all for one tokoyami and the
heroes who have been at gunga all this
time quickly realized that she and soul
must be the one controlling machia and
mount lady is doing her best to protect
Makia from direct attacks by all for one
in order to ensure that the effects of
Shinto's Quirk are not canceled out by
one of all for one's attacks all for one
also quickly figures out what's
happening and he now understands how the
aoyama family managed to deceive him
over the phone shinso had used his quirk
in order to help them fool all for one
the villain states that a brainwashing
Quirk is something that is well suited
to a Villain Like himself but not a hero
and we know that this is one of the
things that shinso is extremely
self-conscious about all for one really
has a gift for getting to people he can
pinpoint someone's greatest weakness and
insecurity very quickly and he can
instantly try to exploit them to his
Advantage all for one then launches an
attack at machia in an attempt to break
the effect of shinzo's brainwashing and
for a moment it looks like it worked
Makia begins to speak and he indicates
that he knows who his real master is
because he can smell him on top of his
hearing being extremely sensitive
makia's sense of smell is also
exceptional but then machia does
something unexpected instead of
immediately switching sides to back up
his master he asks all for one why he
abandoned him in the mountains and told
him to wait for his successor to arrive
Makia has been waiting for his true
master all for one this entire time but
now he feels that he was abandoned by
overwan that moment of Abandonment was
extremely painful for Makia and it had a
profound effect on him initially Hawks
thinks that maybe Shinzo is still
controlling Machi and forcing him to
talk but that's not what's really
happening shinso explains that Makia is
actually resisting his brainwashing and
he is only the second person who was
ever able to resist the first person
being Deku Makia feel feels like he was
betrayed by his master the one that
Makia would have sacrificed everything
for and it seems that this betrayal has
made Makia extremely angry this anger is
what is allowing him to resist the
effects of shin Soul's squirt shinso did
have Maki under control initially but
then he sensed makia's anger and now
he's just kind of letting the anger take
over while he hangs around as a safety
mechanism even though many people call
his brainwashing abilities something
that only a villain would use Shin so
squirrel doesn't actually have the power
to change what is in people's hearts and
so Machias current Rebellion against all
for one is not a result of shinsel's
Quirk the main driving factors of the
Rebellion are makia's feelings of anger
and abandonment towards his master if
Shin Soul was the one controlling him
Makia would be more like a Mindless
obedient zombie he wouldn't be this
passionate and this determined to have
it out with all for one as kirishima
uses his hardened body to protection so
from all for one's attack Mount lady
Dark Shadow and machia launch another
assault on all for one the three attacks
come together to shake the entire
Battlefield emphasizing once again what
an epic and almost biblical battle this
is now let's talk about those two
helicopters that first appeared at the
end of the previous chapter in this
chapter the helicopters are revealed to
belong to members of the media inspired
by the footage of gentle that La Brava
was live streaming at the UA Battlefield
these reporter decided to take control
of a helicopter in order to report on
the climactic battle currently happening
between Deku and shigaraki in fact one
particular reporter remembers Deku from
the time that she had casually
interviewed him about the fact that all
might was now a teacher at UA and she
can't believe how much this young hero
student has grown and changed in such a
short amount of time the second
helicopter is being used by yet another
journalist the one who had been critical
of the heroes during the press
conference after jakku because her
mother had been injured during makia's
rampage this reporter wants to undo the
damage that she feels she has caused by
being so harsh on the heroes at that
press conference and she wants to see
what the heroes who are still fighting
Against All Odds are going to do now
that the situation is so dire these
Heroes kept fighting even after many of
the other Heroes quit these Heroes kept
fighting even after the other countries
abandoned Japan to shigaraki and the
villains and so this reporter wants to
show the world what will happen here
whether the outcome is good or bad to
her this is more personal than
professional and it's clear that she
respects and admires the heroes who are
still standing and still fighting
against seemingly impossible odds oh and
she's also sharing the helicopter with
big news Morgans for some reason
honestly see I wouldn't be surprised if
this Birdman journalist in the second
Chopper is an example of horikoshi
intentionally paying homage to one piece
back on the battlefield beneath the UA
Deku and shigaraki have made contact we
see Deku holding shigaraki by the wrists
in order to prevent him from using the K
while shigaraki laughs maniacally as he
tends to do we don't get to see more of
this battle unfortunately but due to the
way that the Deku panel was drawn it
looks like there might be cracks forming
on his face and especially on his
forehead there's been a lot of
speculation about this on the internet I
mean it could just be an artistic Choice
by horikoshi to emphasize the huge
amount of strain that Deku is under or
it could be something more Sinister it
could be an indication that deku's body
is beginning to collapse under the
strain of overusing all of his quirks
and especially his newest Quirk gear
shift which we were already warned has a
very strict time limit deku's time at
full power is running out and these
cracks could be a sign that it's almost
over for Deku I've seen people
speculating online about these cracks
but again I have to emphasize that it
could be more of an artistic Choice
rather than an indication of deku's
imminent Doom anyway now that these
climactic battles between the remaining
heroes and villains are being both live
streamed and broadcast by reporters and
now that LA brava's live stream of
gentle has reached over 20 000 live
viewers and growing all of Japan and
even the rest of the world is tuning in
everyone is watching the heroes who
retired like death arms International
Heroes like Salam the U.S president and
Admiral Akbar and even movie only
characters from all three mha movies
like Melissa shield mahore and katsuma
and Rudy siblings and many more they are
all watching to see what's happening in
Japan by the way in case you didn't know
the mha movies were always at least
semi-canon they featured characters and
items that later appeared in the actual
manga although some minor changes were
indeed made from the movies to the manga
I think that this emphasis on the entire
world watching the events in Japan could
be a hint that we are heading towards a
more global conflict a World War if you
will it isn't hard to imagine that after
International Heroes see the Japanese
Heroes struggling against the villains
they will be motivated to join the fight
and back up the Japanese Heroes but at
the same time International villains are
out there as well and they could decide
to support the other side we might even
get entire governments getting involved
if the situation gets bad enough so yeah
depending on how this conflict
progresses we could have a major Global
incident happening very soon in this
chapter horikoshi specifically went out
of his way to make sure that we all know
that everyone is watching and that
everything depends depends on the
outcome of these final battles so what
will the outcome be is deku's time
really running out and could his body be
falling apart due to the fact that he
keeps pushing himself too far personally
I do think that his time will run out
soon because the story already
established that he was on a short time
limit with gear shift the only question
is how long Deku will be out of
commission when his time runs out and
who will step up to take on shigaraki
while Deku recovers shigaraki is now at
full power and he has full use of all
his quirks so whoever tries to help Deku
will have a massive challenge before
them and what about the fact that the
whole world is watching this battle do
you think that any International heroes
or even villains may appear and play an
important role in the battle eventually
personally I would like to see some of
them appear because so far star and
stripe was the only one that got any
real screen time but I honestly don't
know if there's enough time for all of
them to be introduced it definitely
feels like we're heading towards the
finale and the end of the entire story
seems closer than ever before finally is
deku's Dad the president of the United
States let me know what you guys think
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it only takes you
a second but it helps me out with that
YouTube algorithm and as I said earlier
if you want to see that big new mha
video that will be coming out soon
possibly the best video we've ever made
here on the channel definitely subscribe
and hit that notification Bell right now
you can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys